I I want to be known as somebody who
believed in and practiced encouraged and
set an example for civilized discourse
about things that matter that is my
simple goal in life fortunately I have
been given the opportunity in the
vehicle to do that which is the NewsHour
I believe that civilized discourse about
the hottest subjects in the world they
can be the most most crushing the most
burning the most controversial things
that you can imagine you can still have
civilized discourse you can still have
somebody over here saying you know this
is blah blah blah somebody's on the
other side and my job and I consider it
my purpose is to make sure that the
people who are doing the talking and
doing the disagreeing do it in a
civilized way in a way that does not
necessarily question the motives of
every somebody who disagrees if they do
it they have to do it on a civilized
they can look at them and do but anyhow
I believe it civilized discourse I
believe that that's how you arrive
through the process Deborah it to arrive
at your own opinions if you if you're
not sure about something and and you
want and and you want to know both sides
or all three sides are all four sides
because most cases there are more than
just wanted just to you what my purpose
and and what I want people to think
about when they think about me and what
we have done and what we created on our
program I want people to think that's
the place I can go and hear all of the
opinions in a way that is understandable
and will help me arrived at my own
opinion when it's all said and done and
that's what I want
well what gives me hope is also it
concerns the concerns are that the good
thing let's start with the great the
good things the good things are there's
more and more information out and
available to everybody then there ever
has been used to be three television
networks and us and your local newspaper
and that was it and you could read the
news magazines whatever but basically
that's how people got their news and was
all shared news at ninety percent of the
people more than ninety percent of the
people had given and at a at an early
evening time had watched one of these
three nightly news you know Hundley
Brinkley Cronkite whatever and so they
all had the same they all got the same
information and they started their their
arguments about it afterward based on
the same set of facts now what's
happened now is there's so many
different ways to get the information in
so many different formats and some
people get their information on Jon
Stewart which is made up news some
people get their information on blogs
which is our is mostly opinionated news
very little original reporting goes on
there and there's cable news and there's
a radio shack shows there's all kinds of
things all kinds of vehicles for getting
information about things that matter and
that's a good thing the bad thing is
that there is sometimes now the the
first time somebody hears about a story
is when they hear the joke first time
they hear about a search when they hear
a strong shouted opinion either on a
blog or on a radio show or whatever and
the first prop the first step which is
the shared in other words anybody have
any opinion they want but but you can't
have any set of facts that you want and
there should be a platform of facts from
which everything else flows then if Jon
Stewart wants to make up for and the
fact of the matter is the good news here
is and the good side of this is there is
an increasing there are increasing signs
that people get this they're sick of
having to to have their first
information come even if somebody from
the left or somebody from the right they
only want to use the only hear from
people it's possible now as you know
because of the what's available on the
internet
ever you can you could hear and listen
and read only from people who agree with
you one hundred percent you would never
ever hear a contrasting view and and you
would know something you would know
something about a particular subject but
the people there is evidence now that
that the folks want they want to not a
return because you know i'm not talking
about going back to nightly news
programs in the old sense but they want
a beginning they want to in here is to
be here here let us begin with the news
and you can get it on a pink ipod with
your name engraved on it or you can get
it at a newspaper said you know sitting
in front of the fireplace or you can get
it watching a television program you can
get it anywhere but but in the beginning
and every end and that to me is both the
good and the bad the bat is that we
haven't gotten there yet and the good is
that there are signs that's going to
their that that there that there is
meaning and purpose and a future I
believe in reporting a new street first
and so you have always believed and we
we have we have all kinds of guidelines
at the news hour which in a state very
clearly there are three legitimate forms
of news there's the straight news the
reporting of the news there's the second
there's the analysis of the news and
then there's opinion about the news the
these are three separate functions and
should be clearly labeled and they
should be done by different people in
other words Billy Bob reporter should
not also be Sammy sue analyst or Jimmy
Charles columnist it all these so
they're so the reader the viewer the
listener whatever Kane knows that okay
this dis is straight news now this
person's are now telling me what the
President of the United States did today
the analyzer is now saying well what
this could mean but this action could
mean this could mean ass could mean this
and somebody else comes on is it what
the president of the day is really awful
it's terrible you know and but each
the person wants the instead of
beginning here but this is awful and
then working back I think we're going to
have a there's they're hopeful signs
that that there's going to be a we're
going to figure out a way to separate
this better the mechanics the
technologies make this possible of
course technology makes everything
possible still takes journalists to do
it in the beginning there is a
journalist some journalist has to has to
go to the courthouse or go to the White
House has to read the original document
has to get the original leak has to do
all of this and those are the folks that
need to be protected and need to be not
and and not be goosed up to Goose up
stories and step over the line to juice
them up and give more opinion and all
that sort of stuff and try to be in it I
tell people all the time you know new
I'm not in the entertainment you want to
be entertained go to the circus don't
watch the news hour and I don't care
whether I don't want i'm not there to
make people laugh or cry or and you have
just give them the facts the best stock
possibly can and then then you other
people could take up and do anything
they want to with them but in the
beginning there must be the news
you